hi I'm Patti Kim our next destination
could easily be described as a piece of
paradise Costa Rica
it's a favorite getaway for both eco
trekkers and the surfs set now if you're
looking to enjoy a bit of a good life
for as they say in Costa Rica Laputa
Vida and this is the place for you Costa
Rica is at the southern end of Central
America bordered to the north by
Nicaragua and Panama to the south it's a
little smaller than the state of West
Virginia and largely mountainous within
strips of lowlands by the Pacific and
Caribbean traditionally focused on
exporting bananas and coffee Costa
Rica's new top industry is tourism
many tourists arrived in the capital San
Jose and head straight for the Pacific
Coast beaches but if you're looking for
something a little out of the ordinary
the country has several prime spots for
volcano watching but the most popular is
Aden out near the town of La Fortuna
since 1968 the volcano has been on a
red-hot eruption spree from the
observation lodge you can watch
alongside volcanologist as animals use
hot ash steam and molten rock the
volcano has also created many hot
springs relax and enjoy the bubbling
water at mountain spas and resorts when
you're ready for a change of pace see
the rainforest from a bird's eye view
attached to a zipline running through
the jungle canopy you can fly from
platform to platform it's an addictive
adrenaline rush take a moment to catch
your breath and you might even catch
sight of some of the rainforest
inhabitants
Costa Rica is rich in wildlife and ranks
as one of the world's most biodiverse
countries its national parks are home to
everything from howler monkeys to
white-faced Capuchin it's a bird
watchers paradise with over 800 species
including two Canz
the cause and the resplendent Quetzal on
the ground
tapirs sniff for food using their short
trucks to grab leaves and fruit
meanwhile huge colonies of leaf cutter
ants prune the forest along riverbanks
the visibility is great for spotting
animals hanging from the treetops so
keep your eyes peeled before they hop
away along the coast turtle watching is
popular especially in April and May
leatherbacks and green turtles lurch up
onto the beach to lay their eggs they
only rest for a little while before
making the return trip back out to sea
you'll find that many animals are
nocturnal so guided tours let you
discover everything that flit scrawls
climbs and goes bump in the night when
planning your trip the right time to go
depends on what you want to do the dry
season for most of the country runs from
December to April the different parts of
the year are best for surfing fishing
and animal watching so there's always
something happening more than 25% of
Costa Rica is protected territory in the
form of national parks forest reserves
and wildlife refuges so bring your
binoculars your sense of adventure and
settle in to a bit of labuda Viva